so what are the basic things that most
uh os's do mobile os's do
um in terms of
helping enforce security like what what
are these features
um in these perhaps somewhat immature
os's that you mentioned that developers
can take advantage of sure so
you know i'll cover two at a very high
level we'll talk about just application
sandboxing first of all that basically
means that your application is running
on the device and it's in its own
protected sandbox it can
potentially write to the file system and
it can write and read to its own files
but it can't necessarily touch the files
of another application
so if your
if your banking application is you know
storing some sort of potentially
sensitive data on a file
uh you know you're the newest game that
you've downloaded can't necessarily out
of the box
reach in and touch and read those bits
of data the operating system won't let
that happen
now when the device is jailbroken those
controls are removed
and now a rogue or malicious application
running on the device is running at a
higher privilege level and can
potentially do a lot a lot of things
that can attack other applications it
can abuse other bits of functionality on
the phone like turn on the microphone
for example or
steal your contacts or send out sms
messages or email
um the
the other bit that you know i'd like to
talk about would be
secure data storage so i've already
talked a little bit about just data
storage on the device writing to files
you don't want to
if you're
for
storing credentials on the device or you
have the need to store credentials on a
device so a user doesn't need to enter
them every time they authenticate to
your app
you don't want to just write them to a
flat text file in plain text on the
device something like that is easily
recoverable
whether or not the device is jailbroken
you know no
and we're talking about applications
attacking it if the person loses their
device you don't want somebody to be
able to pick it up and with minimal
skill or ability be able to pull a file
off your device and now they have your
banking credentials right
so
uh
the platforms provide certain methods of
securely storing data on the devices for
example on ios there's the keychain
data stored in the keychain isn't
necessarily encrypted unless the user
has a passcode on their device
so if they don't have a passcode on
their device and you're as a developer
you're storing something in the keychain
and the device is not jailbroken
you have the application sandboxing so
my app can't access your app's
credentials
um but if an attacker picks up the
device and has physical access to it he
can get at that keychain data and it's
not protected without the passcode
so there are lots of little nuances that
people need to be aware of do you think
developers are commonly aware that this
sort of scenario exists for instance on
an ios
on the ios platform
i think the documentation could always
be
improved upon and there's a lot of
uh just general awareness that that
needs to happen you know it's also very
easy to go down the uh
uh the encryption rabbit hole
where okay we we know we need to protect
this data so let's encrypt it and we'll
use a an ace or a symmetric key
and you come across that uh quite often
when you're when you're reviewing uh
mobile applications where you just
happen to find a hard-coded crypto key
right in the application code base
used to store the credentials and the
file system right encrypted right
but what the developers don't always
realize is that that key is easily
recoverable
and in that case
okay now the key is on
a million devices for the one million
users who've installed your application
so now you've got a situation where
a bad guy can say okay well i see
how poorly this app is protecting the
sensitive data
i can see based on the number of
downloads that it's installed on
you know bazillions of devices
now i can target this application and i
can write a
you know a trojan or some piece of
malware that'll you know masquerade as a
legitimate right mobile application
right
and you know seek out this this other
app right on the installed user base